the gold medal honors in the alternative
category go to a filmmaker who made her
film just up the street at UCLA please
welcome the gold medal award-winning
filmmaker in the alternative category
Robin kanakas
[Applause]
look dad I got it
[Applause]
one of my main goals when I began
production on this film was to win a
student academy award
so first off I wanted to thank the
Academy for helping me achieve this goal
and forgiving me this wonderful
opportunity to start an incredible
future doing exactly what I'm a
passionate about to my parents sister
Tony thank you for your own ship ting 11
support as well as consistent patience
with me throughout the shoot of this
film without you by my side this film
would not have been made or got to this
point of winning an Academy Award
the film could not have been made
possible without the help of my
extremely good friend co-director
producer cinematographer and
collaborator Brian Loschiavo as you can
tell he has had a hand in almost every
process of this film
basically on my interest and all of my
knowledge in stop-motion animation to
him so thank you for being my constant
guiding light to all of my friends that
have stood by my side no matter how many
times I've blowing them off and made
them feel neglected because i was
totally focused on this film thank you
um
drew Hodges who helped me with the
lighting having your presence at the
studio was so comforting knowing that it
had you as a partner in crime shooting
these insane hours at night almost 15
hours a day and I'm
having you threw out all those stressful
moments means so much to me and
to my sound composer he's not here his
name is hannah's Brown he did such a
wonderful job with this film and I think
that it carries almost fifty percent of
the film and
that's what we were taught at UCLA to
really focus on your sound and make that
a huge priority on your film and I think
he did a wonderful job so thank you to
hannah's and last but not least Justin
thank you for flying all the way from
Texas and for sharing this incredible
moment in my life and to all the
filmmakers and the Student Award winners
good luck i look forward to seeing you
in the future thank you so much
[Applause]
you